ma mère je vous ferai savoir est la plus grande personne d'Allah jamais produite dans ce pays vient-elle visiter il n'est pas Pavan je l'ai tuée je suis ici je ne fais pas quel genre de médecin je suis psychiatre dr  .  Lawrence n'est pas rentré hier savez-
vous où il est je vais vous faire un
marché
je veux d'abord trois choses vous devez accepter de
ne pas lire mon dossier
deuxième chocolat dernière condition mademoiselle
Peterson reste en dehors de ça elle est
impliquée je ne suis pas dans le  humeur pour les jeux
je ne sais pas non plus ce que dr.  Lawrence
ne le laisse pas te guider Brooke il est
totalement imprévisible
J'ai toujours été à toi pourquoi ne joues-tu pas
selon mes [ __ ] de règles rejeté Je veux
continuer à l'appeler elle va commencer à
dépenser quelque chose